I'm considering waiting to start chemotherapy.
I ask my ecologist if she could order a CT scan in a month or two to see if there are any changes either way.
I've not heard her answer yet.
My question for you is, is it unrealistic to expect this protocol to show some improvement in one or two months?
I know with God's help, anything is possible, just trying to get a feeling for your experience with people on these protocols.
Okay, so it really depends on a couple of things.
Well, first of all, to come into the, I'm considering the way to start chemo, I asked my ecologist if she could order a CT scan in a month or two to see if there's any changes either way.
Most likely the answer to that question from your ecologist is going to be no.
Because there are some qualifications to be considered in whether your insurance will pay for another CT scan.
If you're not doing the therapy that is recommended, most likely your insurance will not approve another CT scan.
So that's probably not an option.
That's probably going to be what the ecologist would say plus the ecologist would have a bias in that.
Well, if you're not going to do what I'm telling you to do, I'm not going to order another CT scan.
They may be totally okay with ordering blood work for you, as long as your comment to them was, I may want to wait on the chemo.
Could I continue to get blood work while I'm in the decision making process?
I'm not saying no, but I'm just postponing this.
They may be open to continue to do blood work and to see you and do exams and such.
But I don't know about getting an expensive test like a CT scan, whether they'd be open to that, and I'd highly doubt if your insurance would be open to that.
Is it unrealistic to expect that any nutritional rife, any alternative protocol would show improvement in one or two months?
No, it's not unrealistic.
Is it probable?
Maybe it partly depends on the rate that the cancer is growing.
And if you just were diagnosed with cancer and let's say it's staged for, it's metastasized to multiple organs, we don't know the rate that need the speed of growth.
So if it's growing very rapidly, sometimes you need to do some chemo to knock things down.
It would be a little different story.
If a person, and I don't remember who asked this question, what their cancer is, but let's pretend it's a couple scenarios so we could get a better example.
If a woman had a lump in her breast and she palpated that lump and felt there was something wrong and finally went in after several months, this is not getting any better.
I went through a diagnostic procedure and she was diagnosed with breast cancer and the lump was the size of a grape.
And the oncologist told her we need to do chemotherapy right away to shrink it and then we're going to do surgery that's typical scenario with a lump in the breast.
And the woman said, is it unrealistic for me to do, you know, a natural protocol, whatever that consists of.
If I can prove it in one or two months, I would say that's not unrealistic because we know the cancer is so far just contained in one spot.
You just noticed it, you know, six months ago, you have a lump, whatever size it is, and it hasn't changed dramatically over the time that you've noticed it.
Is it realistic to give it 30 to 60 days to see if we can stop the growth of it? I think that's very realistic.
But if a different scenario was the woman had a lump in her breast, she went in and had a biopsy, it was positive for cancer and she had an MRI and she had metastasis to the lungs, metastasis to the bone.
And is that going to be the same scenario? Well, no, because it's further down this down stage.
And is it unrealistic to see, is it unrealistic to expect that the nutritional protocol is going to see improvement?
I don't, I wouldn't say it's not realistic. Everything's possible.
We've seen miraculous changes in people, but the probability is lower.
So if a person is in a later stage cancer, the probability goes down.
Now, again, this is so dependent on every case. If the person was given a chemotherapy regimen that was basically not curative,
meaning we're going to just do chemo because that's all we got to do, your stage four, we don't have anything else.
If that's really what's being offered, then I would say that it's not that you're necessarily expecting giant changes,
but you're, you're really trying to have a protocol that's going to give you a much longer life and hopefully be curative, but have no side effects.
I don't see any problem with, with postponing things as long as you stay on top of, you know, subjective findings,
as my pain gotten worse, objective findings. Can I monitor this with different blood work?
You could get lots of clues in blood work, whether your cancer is growing or not.
Let's say you look at a CBC with differential, if you have an increase prevalence of anemia is going to be assigned that the cancer is growing.
That's a possibility. It increases in your alkaline phosphatase. It increases in your calcium. That's all signs that your cancer is growing.
If you have positive tumor marker tests that are showing up and you do a subsequent test in two weeks and you're doing blood work every two weeks,
and your tumor markers are double lead, that's a sign that we need to use something else to try to knock this down.
The alternative perspective approach is not, you know, stealthful enough to knock this down on its own.
So there are ways to monitor it, short of getting a CT stand, which probably won't be approved.
So you can, you know, do blood work at a very regular basis. I've had people start when we're doing blood work weekly.
So we want to keep a close eye on this and they're willing, you know, even if their oncologists won't order that, we can order that blood work.
And, you know, it's not super expensive, like a $5,000 CT scan.
And we can order that and keep an eye on it and make sure we're not going severely in the wrong direction.
Either way, I would always be super kind to my oncologists, be very thankful to them.
Even if you prayed about this and prayed about this and you don't feel peace about moving forward with chemotherapy,
I would still tell them that exactly what is going on honestly and praying about this and don't feel peace about moving forward.
It doesn't mean I'm saying no, I'm just saying no for right now.
I really appreciate you and I want to keep a relationship with you.
That would be my recommendation and how you talk to a oncologist.
If they get angry and they, you know, they're the my way or the highway type personality, then just go to a different oncologist.
You'll find somebody who will work with you however you want to be worked with and understands your case and your dilemma and your spirituality in this and your decision making process.
So we just want to keep an eye on it.
So if a person comes to me and they have stage 4 cancer, they're like, I don't want to do chemo, then we do want to keep an eye on things close more closely.
Hope that helps.